what do you think about somebody like
donald hoffman who thinks the reality is
an illusion
so complete illusion that we're
given this
actually really nice definition
or idea that you talked about that
there's a tension between the the
illusory and the and what is real
he says that basically we
taken that
and we ran with the real to the point
where
the real is
not
at all connected to some kind of
physical reality
i hope to talk to him at some point we
were supposed to talk at one point and
so i have to talk in his absence um
i i think that first of all i think
saying that everything in his illusion
is like saying everything is tall it
doesn't make any sense it's a
comparative term um something you have
you you're you have to say against this
standard of realness this is an illusion
and
he uses
arguments like from evolution which are
problematic to me because it's like well
you seem to be saying that
evolution is true that it really exists
and
then
some of our cognition and a perception
has access to reality math and
presumably some science has access to
reality and then
what he seems to be saying is well
a lot of your everyday experience is
illusory but that we do have some
contact with reality whereby we can make
the arguments as to why most of your
experience most of your everyday
experience is an illusion but to me
that's not a novel thing that's that's
that's descartes that's the idea that
most of our sense experience is
untrustworthy but the math is what
connects us to reality that's how he
interpreted the copernican revolution oh
look we're all seeing the sun rise and
move over and set and it's all an
illusion but the math
the math gets us to the reality well i
think he makes a deeper point that most
of cognition
is just is evolved and operates in the
illusory world how does he know that
things like cognition and evolution
exist
i think there's an important distinction
between evolution
and cognition
right no no i'm just saying that's not
the point i'm making i'm making a point
that he's claiming that there are two
things that really exist
why are they
privileged he basically says
that look the process of evolution makes
sense yes right like it makes sense that
you get complex organisms from simple
organisms through the natural selection
process
here's how you get to transfer
information from generation to
generation it makes sense and then he
says
that
there's no requirement for the cognition
to evolve in a way
that it would actually perceive and have
direct contact with the physical reality
except that cognition evolved in such a
way that it could perceive the truth of
evolution and you can't treat evolution
like an isolated thing evolution depends
on darwinian theory genetics it depends
on understanding plate tectonics the way
the environment changes it depends on
how chromosomes are structured actually
that's an interesting question to him
where
i don't know if he actually would
push back on this is how do you know
evolution is real yes
i think he would be open to the idea
that it is part of the illusion we
constructed that there's some
it's it's it's in some sense it is
connected to
reality but we don't have a clear
picture of it
i mean
that's a that's an intellectually honest
statement then if most of our cognition
yeah
as thinking beings is operating
at every level
in an illusory world
then it makes sense that this
one of the main theories of science
that's evolution
is is also
a com a complete part of this illusory
world right but then what happens to the
premise for his argument
leading to the conclusion that cognition
is illusory i i think he makes a very
specific argument about evolution as an
explanation of why the world is of our
cognition operating in the illusory
world but
that's that's just one of the
explanations i i think the deeper
question is
why do we think we have contact with
reality
with physical reality it's it we could
be
very well living
in a virtual world
constructed by our mi by our minds in a
way that makes that world
deeply interesting in some ways whether
it's somebody playing a video game
or we're trying to
through the process of distributed
cognition construct
uh more and more complex objects like
why do we have to
why why does it have to be connected to
like physics and planets and all that
kind of stuff okay so if we're going to
say
like
we're now considering it as a
possibility rather than it's a
conclusion based on arguments because
the arguments again will always rely on
stipulating that there is something that
is known
these are the features of cognition
cognition is capable of illusion that's
a true statement you're somehow in
contact with the mind why is the mind
have this privileged contact and other
aspects like my body do not so that's
but let's put that aside and now let's
just consider it
now
when it when we put it that way it's not
an epistemic question anymore it's an
existential question and here's my reply
to you there's two possibilities
either
the illusion is one that i cannot
discover
sort of you know the the matrix on
steroids or something there's no way no
matter what i do i can't find out that
it's an illusion
or
it's an illusion but i can find out that
it's an illusion
those are the two possibilities
nothing changes for me if those are the
two possibilities because if i cannot
find possibly find out
it is irrational for me to pay any
attention to that possibility
so i could she should keep doing the
science as i'm doing it if
there's a way of finding out
science is my best bet i believe for
finding out if it's a
what's true and what's an illusion so i
keep doing what i'm doing so it's an
argument if you move it to that that
makes no existential difference to me
oh man that is such an a
deeply philosophical argument no no no
no no
nobody's saying
science doesn't work
it's an interesting question just like
before humans were able to fly they
would ask a question can we build the
machine that makes us fly in that same
way we're asking a question to which we
don't know an answer but we may know in
the future
how much of this whole thing
is an illusion
and i think in the second category the
first guy i forgot which one yes science
will be able to help us discover this
uh otherwise yes for sure
it doesn't matter if we're living in a
simulation we can't find out at all yes
then it doesn't matter but yes the whole
point is as we get deeper and deeper
understanding
of uh our mind of cognition
we might be able to discover like how
much of this is a big charade
constructed by our mind to keep us fed
or something like that some some weird
uh some weird very simplistic
explanation that will ultimately in its
simplicity be beautiful
or as we try to build robots and instill
them
instill them with
consciousness with
ability to feel
those kinds of things we'll we'll
discover
well we let's just trick them into
thinking they feel and have
consciousness and they'll believe it and
then they'll have a deeply fulfilling
and meaningful lives and on top of that
they will interact with us in a way
that'll make our lives more meaningful
and then all of a sudden it's like at
the end of animal farm you look at pigs
and humans you look at robots and humans
you can't tell the difference between
either and we in that way start to
understand that
um
that
much of this existence could be an
illusion
okay well i have two responses to that
uh first is
uh the progress that's being made on
like agi
is about making
whatever
the system is that's going to be the
source of intelligent
more and more dynamically and
recursively self-correcting
that's part of what's happening
extrapolating from that you get a system
that gets better and better at
self-correcting but that's exactly what
i was describing before as the
transformative theory of truth
the other response to that is
science like
people think of science just as
right sort of end proposition but let me
just use the evolution example again
right
like i need i i i need
if i if i'm gathering the evidence i
need to know a lot of geology i need to
know plate tectonics i need to know
about radioactive decay i need to know
about genetics and then and and then in
order to measure all those things i need
to know how to how microscopes work i
need to know how pencils and paper work
i need to know how rulers work i need to
know how english like
like you can't isolate knowledge that
way
and if you say well most of that's an
illusion then you're in a weird position
of saying somehow all of these illusions
get to this truth claim
i think it it goes in reverse if you
think this is the truth claim
right the measuring and all the things
that scientists would do to gather on
all the ways the theories are are
converging together that also has to be
fundamentally right because it's not
like lego it is an interwoven whole yes
it definitely is interwoven but i love
how i played that i'm playing the devil
advocate for for the illusion world but
uh there's a consistent i mean there's
an aspect to truth that has to be
consistent deeply consistent across an
entire system but inside a video game
that's some kind that some same kind of
consistency evolves there's rules about
interactions there's
game theoretic patterns about what's
good and bad and so on you you get and
there's sources of joy and fear and
anger and and then understanding about
the world what happens in different
dynamics of a video game even simple
video games so there's no
you know even in an inside an illusion
you could have consistency and develop
truths inside that illusion and
uh
iteratively evolve your truth with the
illusion okay but that comes back
does that is that process genuinely
self-correcting or are you in the
simulation in which there is no possible
doorway out
because if my argument is if you find
one or two doorways that feeds back in
fact you can't just say this is the
little tiny island where we have the
truth that's the point i'm making right
but what if
you find that i think there is doorways
if that's the case and what if uh you
find a door when you step out
but you're yet in another simulation
i mean that's the point that's so
self-correcting
when you fix the self-deception
you don't know if there's other bigger
self-deceptions you're operating of
course in one sense that's right but
again we're back to when i step into the
second simulation
is it uh can i get the doorway out of
that or right because if you just make
the infinite regressive simulations you
basically said i have a simulation that
i can never get out of
you